in bucharest gary kasparov said that
probably uh the winner of the candidates
tournament is sitting in this playing
fault you think about yourself at that
moment how sure you are you were before
this event but i think he had a very
nice guess because it was like 50 50 of
players yeah like four out of eight yeah
exactly so he had uh
you know
chances yeah i mean uh even like uh if
he would like call four random names it
still like would be fifty percent
because
somehow i believe that before the
tournament okay everyone has like about
well it's eight players so everyone has
like 12 and a half
and uh due to some uh i don't know
aspects like okay for me for me it was
second candidates and so on
it was um you know maybe i had less
slightly more but i never thought about
myself as a favorite yeah so maybe this
also like helped me quite quite a bit
because
uh somehow through all the tournaments i
was i mean also because of the
tournament situation yes i succeed but i
just was trying to play chess not to
play for results not to win games
uh and
i think it's
quite a smart you know mindset
i would say comparing especially to the
second lack of yakitori and burkya when
i was
trying to hold my like plus two and then
okay i was like basically very lucky to
get some
easy
you know relatively easy games against
so
accurately sync and then against
how yes or some surprising queen that we
always like uh was completely unexpected
but uh yeah anyway i was trying only you
know to to keep my lead
and uh
uh i mean it was no place and no no
space for you know for creativity for uh
i don't know if you're enjoying but here
i mean of course when you're leading the
tournament you can't enjoy it because
you are too much afraid of losing the
leadership
here somehow i think it was
you know corrected to the to right side
also magnus didn't think that you are a
favorite because i just caught him today
on display in the venue and i asked him
if i are you going to play the match he
said maybe we will see his head actually
so what are your thoughts
you're looking well maybe we will see
the same ones
yeah okay so how are you going to
celebrate your victory
how special it is for you
i mean it's uh quite a quite a mixed
feeling because okay last year i also
managed to win okay one around in
advance
and then they had a disastrous last
round so
hopefully i won't spoil my own party so
tomorrow i should play a good game
and in case if i want to spoil it it can
again i will celebrate
okay have a good game thank you very
much jan and once again congratulations
thank you